サッブパパッサアカラナン クサラッサウパサンパダ サチッッタパリオダパナン エタング ブッダナ サーサナン
では よろしくお願いいたします
では 今日の話に入ります
テーマ見られる通り 思いやりを育てるという
まあ一応その言葉を聞いた途端
皆様は俗世間のことを考えるでしょうね
皆様方も一応思いやりということは大事なものであるとは思っています
しかし 問題があります
仏教は一般人の知識レベルでは語りません
いつでもちょっと超越した世界のことを案内するんですね
はい そういうところも覚悟していただきたいと思います
はい それからできるだけ早くスピーディーに進めたいと思います
内容は難しいんだけど
スピーディーに行きます
そうすると皆様にできるだけいくつかでも質問の時間を与えたいんです
はい このよく人間にあること
この相手の気持ちを知りたいと
で 私はちょっと大胆なことを言います
生命は自我中心で貪瞋痴の衝動で生きています
それ毎日言っていることですね
で 相手のことを知りたいとは
相手を自分の利益に使用するためなんです
いい気持ちじゃない 相手のことをよく理解できないまま理解し
母親が子供のことを理解したくなくても同じことなんですよ
自分の相手を自分の利益に使用するためなんです
だって子供のためやと思ったっても
子供がよくしっかり成長すると楽しいのはお母さんですからね
子供にとって別に楽しくないんです
よく勉強できなくてもね
大変苦しい世界ですからね
お母さんは勝手に楽しがってますからね
よく頑張ってるんだとか
ですから 親子関係であっても
相手を知りたがるのは
相手を自分の利益に使うためなんですよ
だから世間のことを言うまでもないでしょう
だから 私たちもね 素直に正直に考えれば
人の気持ちを理解したいと思ってるんです
私はそれいかに危険かと知ってますよ
個人的に なぜならば 我々修行の結果
もう簡単に読めるんですね
読めたところで 心に悪がないんだからいいんだけど
いかにこの人を操れるのかと
いたって簡単なんですね
洗脳することやら マインドコントロールすることやら
ものすごい簡単なんです
もう何でもやらせられるんですよ
だからこれってとんでもない罪なんですね
だから我々は 仏道の世界では
人の心を理解する気持ちをわかるような能力が出てくると同時に
心から汚い罪を落とすんです
はっきり言えば その貪瞋痴の衝動が落とせない限りは
この気持ちが生まれてこないんです
専門家がうなぎの生態系を調べているのは
うなぎの幸福利益のためではありませんね
これわかりやすい例ですよ
いまだにうなぎはどこで卵を産んでどうやって海で生活かわからないんですね
調べているんですよ なぜかというと
このうなぎを卵を産んでもらって
そこで養殖できるんじゃないかなとかね
そうするといっぱい食べられるぞとか思ってるんですね
だから うなぎの生態はどうなっているのかとか
それなんで研究しているのか
要はうなぎを知りたいでしょ
あれはうなぎのため？じゃないんです
自分に利益がなければ
家族さえも捨ててしまうのは普通です
我々は家族を大事にとか謳ってはいるんだけど
家族のメンバーたちから何の利益もない
利益っていうのは この狭い意味ではなく
ちょっと広い意味で考えてください
利益っていうのは まあ家族と一緒にいて楽しい
それも利益なんですね
家族がすくすくと成長すると自分が幸せ
家族がいつでもニコニコニコニコ笑ったりしてね
すごい明るくいると 自分一人にとってはいいなと思っちゃう
それさえも利益なんです
ですから もし家族からはそういうのは何もない
喧嘩するわ 馬鹿にされるわ
自分の金を取り上げるわ
殴られるわとかね そういうことになってくると
へっちゃで家族を捨てるんです
だからそれっていうのは普通だと思いますよ
なぜならば 我々は貪瞋痴で生きているからなんです
互いの気持ちを理解することについて喋りましょう
仲間として生きている場合は
互いに理解し合うことは基本的な条件なんですね
我々は仲間で仲間で生きていますね
家族も一つの仲間なんですね
そうすると お互い理解していないと成り立たないんですね
というわけで 会社でみんなお互い話通じてよく理解し合っているならば
会社はうまくいく クラスの生徒さんたちがお互いにすごい気持ちを通じ合っているならばうまくいく
教師と生徒たちがすごく気が合っているならばOKなんですね
これ 仲間でグループで活動する場合は
やっぱり相手の気持ちを理解する必要が出てくるんですね
ライバルとライバル 敵同士であっても
相手を理解できれば安全です
これは仲間だけじゃない
ライバル同士であっても
相手のことをよく分かった方が安全でしょ
敵の場合でも 敵のことはよく分かっているんだったら
こちらが安全なんですね
敵を攻撃するなりに攻撃の方法を知っているし
敵から身を守ることだったら
相手のことをよく知っているんだから
身を守ることができます
ですから この仲間同士だけではなく
敵同士であっても互いに理解した方がよろしいということになるんです
人間関係の問題も 相手を正しく理解していないか
誤解しているかの結果です
では 我々人間関係でいつだって何かしらトラブルなんですね
いつだってトラブル 親と子の間でトラブル
夫婦の間でトラブル いつ友達の間でもトラブルとかね
人間でいつでもトラブっちゃうんですね
これどういうことかというと
相手を理解していないか
あるいは誤解している
どちらかなんです 思考を理解するのは簡単ですが
思考を引き出す感情を理解しなくてはいけませんね
それでこの理解するといえば
いろいろ理解あるんですよ
この全体的に理解しなくてはいけない
思考だけ考えることだけだったらすぐ分かれます
人間同士で 例えば学校で教師が教えている
で 教師の思考でしょ 教師は何者か
どんな人間か 生徒たちはさっぱりわからない
どこに住んでいるのか
結婚しているのか 子供がいるのかとか
何もわからない 好みは何なのか
好物は何なのかわからない
わからないんだけど 教師が教えているんだから
それは理解できる 思考だけは理解できる
だから世の中で勉強というものは問題なく成り立っているんですね
勉強するために 先生のことを全部知っておく必要はないんです
授業だけ聞けばいいんです
しかし 例えば私のこの講演を聞いただけで
この講演を皆様理解したからといって
スマナサーラという人間を理解できますか？できないんですね
だからスマナサーラという人間を理解できなくても
私の好物は何なのかと知らなくても
喋っていることは理解することはできます
はい それで人間関係は築けませんよ
それだけだったら だからこの思考を引き起こすスマナサーラという人間が何者かと
どんな気持ちで どんな性格でというところまで知ったら
もうすごい仲良くすることも
あるいはすごい敵同士になることどちらかできます
この感情を理解しなくていけませんね
相手の思考だけを理解すると騙されます
よくこの宗教世界でね
よく納得いくことが喋って喋って
信者さん孤独して金も取り上げちゃって
相手が贅沢三昧で言いたいやりたいことをやって生活するとかね
いつでもありますよ 日本の歴史で
もう最近のね  20年  30年の間での宗教は現れるでしょう
見たらみんな同じことをやっちゃうんですね
で この人を調べないからね
言葉に騙される 言葉っていうのはいくらでも巧みに使えます
例えば ものすごい嘘をつく人間にも
嘘で固まっている人間にでも
嘘をついてはいけませんとお説教することできるでしょう
できます でも騙されてるでしょ
はい これはちょっともっと柔らかい世界に持っていきます
消費者の気持ちという
商品を開発する場合 当然消費者の気持ち
好み 流行りなどを考えます
ね 消費者を心配するのではなく
品物をヒットさせたいだけです
消費者のことを心配していないんです
自分の品物をヒットさせたいだけなんです
あのジョブズさんみたいに人間がどうでもいいんです
高い値段を設定して買っちゃうと
そうすると我々は騙されて買うしかなくなっちゃうんですね
消費者の弱みを把握すると
無理に感情を押し付けることもあります
コマーシャルにいつでも出てくるのはセリフでしょ
今テレビ見ないんだからわからないんだけど
私は学生時代よくテレビを見ていたんですね
あの日本の車 小さな車を宣伝して
日本の中では小さい車がいっぱい使われているし
まあバカでかい車はあまり面倒くさいんだからね
で アメリカとかヨーロッパと違いますから
で この小さい車のコマーシャルを見ても
アメリカのハリウッドの俳優さんたち
ものすごい背が高くて 2
メートルの巨体の人間入れちゃうんですね
出てくるは出てくるは
あれは嘘でしょうに あんな 4人 5
人 6人乗れません 我々も皆様もね
アジア人だから小柄でしょうし
ある程度日本人はそれほど小柄ではないんだけど
まあ3人乗ったって窮屈ですけど
これですっごい体格のある人々が6人ぐらい出てきて
で 車を紹介すると あれ
何をやっているかというと
やっぱりハリウッドの有名な俳優さんだから
そちらに引かれちゃうんですね
そちら我々は弱みを持ってるんですね
自分の何といいますか
自分がファンなんですね
あの人が出る映画なんか全部全部見てやるぞとかね
それぐらい自分がもう感情的にファンになっているんですね
だから一般的にみんな誰のファンでしょうか
その人に金払ってコマーシャルに出させると
だから売りたい品物とあの連中は何の関係もない
歯磨き 歯ブラシの宣伝の場合は
あの その出るタレントさんが先に専門家に頼んで歯を真っ白くしてもらわなくちゃあかんのです
それからこれで磨いたらこんな感じになるぞと
また光でピッとも光も出してくれるんです
嘘ばっかりでね このブランド思考って何ですかね
どうしてもブランドの品物を使いたいでしょ
大したことないんです
私の個人的な経験なんですと
例えば履き物とかね 私も一応外国のもの入ってますけど
ブランドでね で あの日本でね
ちょこちょこ作っているものありますよ
結構いいんですけど それで私はあの
今履いてるそれともう一つ
ネットであの日本製っていうものを買ったんです
安かったんですね 安くて買って履いてみたら
ものすごい履き心地がいいんです
足にぴったし でも売れない
ブランドの名前ないんです
ただ ネットで売ってんのは
これはあの日本製であるだけなんですね
そういうわけで 我々は品物よしあしではなくて
バッジが何なのかと調べる
だから騙されていない
食べるものの場合も 食べ物を調べていいものを選べばいいのに
やっぱりバッジで 調べちゃうんですね
政治家が言う国民の気持ちとは
政治家の自利的な気持ちなんです
これ 日本でよく聞きます
国民はこんなことを認めません
お前認めないだけでしょう
だから冗談でも政治家の話には乗ってはいけません
完璧嘘をついているんです
仕方がなく権力取ったら仕事をしなくちゃいけない
それだけです そういうわけで
私は何言いたいかというと
人を理解しないで 人の思考だけ聞いちゃうと
この羽になるんです 結構騙されます
で 日本人の中で日本の政治家が一番口達者なんです
もう 気をつけちゃいます
喋る時は すごい能力があるんです
惹かれます だから惹かれてしまいます
同時に騙されます そういうわけで
我々は俗世間でどうしますかね？問題があるんですよ
相手を理解しなくちゃいけない
でなきゃ平和で生きていられません
家族を理解しないと家族は幸せになれない
会社の同僚を理解しておかないと
会社で気持ちよく仕事をできない
会議でお互い理解し合わないといい会議はできません
それは一つの問題 そこで我々は至って簡単だから
言葉を理解する 思考を理解する
思考だけ理解しちゃっちゃうと
いたも簡単に騙されてしまう
その理由は この貪瞋痴にあるんですね
そこで俗世間に対して
私は中道を歩みましょうと言っているんです
弱肉強食 殺す 食うか食われるか
世界は以上の通りですね
我々生きる世界はもう弱肉強食ですよ
文句言ったっても 嫌だなと言ったってしょうがないんです
北極は寒いでしょう 文句言ってどうなる？意味がないんです
だから生命といえば もう弱肉強食で
食うか食われるか世界で生きています
我々人間も同じなんです
そこを正直に理解してほしい
我々も食うか食われるか世界で生きているんです
それに文句を言っても意味がないんです
ですから安心できませんね
ちょっとしたことでやられちゃいます
ちょっとの失敗で全て終わっちゃいます
ちょっと言葉を誤っただけで大変なことになるんです
もう生きていられない
気をつけて気をつけて気をつけていたっても疲れますからね
それで一言を間違えちゃいます
それで全て今まで築いたものは壊れてしまう
例えば日本ではね 麻薬問題それほどはないんだけど
でもたまたま使っている人々はいる
その中で誰か麻薬所持して所有
何て言ったってわからない
使って捕まったら まあそれはアホがやったことでね
よく叱ってね もう治療してあげて治しちゃえばいいでしょう
そうじゃないんです 社会から追い出すんです
タレントさんにしたっても
あまりにもきつい仕事をやってますから
やっぱりクタクタで お金もあるしね
世界に歩き回っているし
手に入りますよ 入っちゃうと使う
使って見つかったらもうタレント仕事からも追い出しちゃうんです
はい そこまでその人を社会から追い出すべき
なんで助けてあげて 麻薬問題解決してあげてね
協力しないんですかね
へっちゃらで非難 侮辱するんで
時々面白いことはテレビでなんとか言ったらこれですかと言って非難する
もうキャスターたちも自分でもやってますけどね
だからそれは私はこの食うか食われるか世界だから
ほんのちょっとのミスで捕らわれちゃうんだ
野生と同じなんですよ
野生が走るんだけど ちょっとでも足がこけちゃったら終わり
走った方向間違ったら終わり
で この自然番組で見たことあるんだけど
このもう乾季でもう動物たちがすっごく喉が渇いて渇いてしょうがない
もう我慢できない そこで水のところに行く
行ったら全部動物たちが来ているんだから
とても危険なんですね
そこでワニたちが来ているんですね
ワニって見えないんですね
動物たちに 人間も見えないんですよ
で 水面のちょっとしか待ってるんですね
下になって よく見ると目とかね
ちょこちょこって見えますけど
鼻の穴とかは でももうくたくた
もう喉が渇いちゃって
もう我慢できない だからそれで水見た瞬間で
ちょっと口を水に入れて
入れた瞬間でぱくっと食べられちゃいます
だから ほんのわずかなミスで野生では命が終わりますよ
これは人間の社会も同じなんですね
ですから 我々はどうすればいいんで
我々は中道を歩むんです
こうかくあるのかというこれを捨てちゃうんです
じゃあ 食うか食われるかの中道って何ですかね？半分食われて半分食ってやるんですかね
それでも終わりですから
半分食われたって終わりですから
自分の命は 自分の利益を重んじることをやめる
まず自分の利益だけ考えることはとても危険です
やめましょう 損被害を受けないようにも気をつける
自分の利益を重んじないんだけど
被害を受けることもしない
損することも気をつける
いわゆる利益ばっかり求めていかない
そこはちょっと気持ちはまあまあ
利益があればありがたいな程度で終わっちゃう
それより損しないことに気をつける
常にウィンウィン状態を考える
それで中道なんです 逆の気色
食のはもうどちらでもダメなんですね
食う世界も食われる世界もダメなんです
ウィンウィン状態 たまに動物の世界であります
たまに人間には誰にだってできる
サメってすごい凶暴な魚でしょ
でもサメの一緒にいる仲間がいるんですよ
サメでない他の魚たちが
あっち行ったりこっち口の中にも入ったり出て行ったり
すごい仲がいい 時々歯の掃除する魚たちがいるんですよ
凶暴な魚のところにちっちゃいんだけどね
行ったらあの魚が口を開ける
あとで口の中に入って全部歯を掃除してあげてるんです
そこはウィンウィン状態なんです
小魚たちが この凶暴な魚がいっぱい食べてるんだから
結構食べ残しがあるんですね
自分では狩りできませんだから
あの歯の間の食べ残しを全部食べる
それで満腹になる 大きい魚にしてみれば
歯医者さんにはお金を払わなくちゃいけないし
これはタダで もう歯の治療をしてくれたんですね
そこはウィンウィン状態なんです
これがあるべき世界の流れです
これがあるべきということはあるじゃないんですね
これがあるべきなんです
いつでも品物を開発する場合は
この品物が人間の役に立ってほしいと
買った人は損して欲しくないんだと
品物を買った人が得してほしいと思わないと
それで消費者が得する
同時に作っている側も得しているんです
品物を買ってるんだから
今はそうじゃないんですね
品物を買っても騙された状態でうまくいかない
そういうことで 我々は消費者としていろいろ物は買う
買う場合は 作ったところには利益が行く
買った品物が私にとってすごく役に立っている
払ったお金は損ではないんです
なんでそういう世界を作らないんですかね
ウィンウィン世界 そうすると世界は平和でしょ？倒産する恐れが消えるでしょ
失業の恐れも消えるでしょ
互いに助け合っているんだと
日本ではないんだけど
他の国々ではもう労働者の問題
大変なんですね いや 取ってあげたっても仕事をしてくれないわ
ストやるわ 攻撃デモをやるわ
なんだこりゃと ですから
それはウィンウィン状態じゃなくて
食うか食われるかっていう法則でやっているからなんです
食うか食われるかって法則っていうのを動物もやってるんだから
あまりシャレにならないんですね
だから人間にもできることはあるんです
人間にだけできること
それはウィンウィン状態で生きてみるんです
子育ての場合もウィンウィン状態作れますよ
夫婦関係でもウィンウィン状態作れますよ
それがあるべき姿です
流れです 世の中って流れですからね
はい そこ そこ世間のところはそこら辺で終了します
それから仏教の世界 貪瞋痴の害を最小限にするだけでは意味がありません
仏教以外の宗教も説法はしている
道徳は語っている しかし
よく調べると 彼らがこの貪瞋痴の害をできるだけ少なくしようと
例えばキリスト教では隣人愛しなさいとLOVE thy neighborというね
いいフレーズあるんですよ
それで隣人を憎むよりは被害が少なくはなります
仏教はあまり気に入らないんです
ちょっと被害が少なくしただけで
意味がありませんと 仏教でなくてもこれはできることですよ
貪瞋痴の被害を少なくすることはね
どんな宗教でもね 言ってますよ
欲少なく怒らないで 神を信仰して
ヨガでもやって 菜食主義になっちゃってとかね
あれやこれやとかね あるいはイスラム教だったら五回のサラってやって
五回のお祈り そうすると
あんな凶暴な殺人鬼の連中が五回神にお祈りするんだから
いくらかは抑えられてますよ
あの五回の一日五回の御間礼なんて言いますかね
サラ彼ら単語はサラですけどね
1 日 5回神に祈ることをやめちゃったら
これより10倍凶暴になるんです
あのテロリストたちも相手を殺そうといくんだけど
このサラの時間になっちゃう
ちょっと待って 神様にお祈りして
それから行くんです その間に逃げればいいんです
アッラーの神様は キリスト教の神様よりはすごい認知症なんです
すぐ忘れるんです だから 1 日 5回見なきゃ忘れちゃいます
キリスト教の神様は週一回で十分です
覚えておくんです ですから
善行による生き方を推薦します
仏教は善善行為をしなさいと言うんです
仏教でいう善行為はちょびっと違うんです
神に言われたからやるんじゃないんです
俗世間の生き方と合ったり合わなかったりもしますが
真理に基づいた生き方なので仕方がありません
説明します 仏教が語る善行為的な生き方は
俗世間に合う場合もあります
俗世間に合わない場合もあります
僕は気にしない 例えば
嘘をつくなかれという場合は厳しい
決して嘘をついてはいけません
例外はありませんと 殺すなかれと言ったら例外はありません
他の命を奪ってはならない
俗世間では蚊ぐらいはね
殺してもいいでしょう
ゴキブリぐらいはね 野菜畑に来る昆虫たちは殺さなくちゃいかんでしょう
そうすると殺生だよ これで言っちゃうと
仏教は嫌いということになっちゃうんです
だから仏教は言わない
私に聞いたこと何回もあります
この野菜作っている人々は
虫が帰っちゃうんだと
そうすると品物はもう売り物にならないんだと
だから殺虫剤かけなくてはいけないでしょうにと
だからそれどうします？殺生界とは
それで私はもう宗教家だったらね
自分の利益だけ考える宗教家だったら
その場合は仕方がないね
はい それ以外で殺さないでくださいとは言わなくちゃあかんでしょ
言いません 俗世間に合わない場ってところはあるんです
合うところもあるんです
時々また私に聞かれて質問です
人殺しにならなきゃ みんなそれは当たり前と思っちゃうんですね
思っているのに もし戦争になったらどうしますか？と
軍隊に入らなくちゃいけなくなったらどうしますか？と
自分の国を攻めたらどうしますか？と
その時殺さなくちゃいかんでしょ
それはどう？それは殺人
バレしかないでしょ そうすると
この人の教えはもう合わないと却下されちゃいますね
私はびくともしません
合わせませんよ 皆様の汚れた貪瞋痴に
だからこれは真理なんですね
生命が貪瞋痴で生きているんだから
悩み苦しむ の世界 恐ろしい苦しみの世界で生きているんです
だったら貪瞋痴を取り除かなきゃいけないんです
その方法はどうしようもないんです
だから仏道の善行為とは
貪瞋痴を弱めて弱めて弱めて消す
根こそぎ取り除く道なんです
善行為とは貪瞋痴を制御することです
神に好まれるから隣人を愛することじゃないんです
仏教では慈しみを実践しなさいと言うんです
それはブッダが言ったからではなくて
命あるものは慈しんだ方が楽に生きられます
それだけの話 そうすると自分の怒り
自我 傲慢さ 優越感 それがなくなりますね
やはり精神的に健康になるんです
次 仏教的に喋ります また
次じゃなくて全部仏教的
これからは相手を理解することは簡単です
これから仏教の技を教えます
悪用しないでください
生きる衝動は貪瞋痴です
だから簡単でしょ 飼っている犬であろうが猫であろうが
飼っているトカゲさんであろうか
みんな生命は貪瞋痴で生きている
自分の野菜に来ている昆虫たちも貪瞋痴で生きている
花畑に来るミツバチも貪瞋痴で生きているんです
ます 自分の貪瞋痴の感情の働き方を観察する
第一 自分 自分も生命の一個ですから
貪瞋痴で生きています
貪瞋痴と言ってもよくわからない
貪瞋痴は活動するんですよ
活動するとわかるんです
例えば波もない湖がある
湖みたいなところ ポンドみたいなところでね
波もない時々ありますね
それで中に魚がいるんだけど
よくわからない それで一匹の魚が活動する
ぐっと動いたり ちょっと飛んでみたりするとわかります
あ 魚もいるんだなって
そこで初めてわかるんです
初めからいたんだけど
水の中に潜ってじっくり見ているとわからない
それでその魚さんが動いちゃったりして
ビシビシビシと泳ぎだすと
波が揺れますから あ 魚がいるんだとわかる
それでよくよく見ると
どんな魚かとも発見することができます
そのように我々には貪瞋痴あるんだけど
よくわからない しかし
貪瞋痴が活動するんですね
活動するとわかります
そういうわけで ます 自分の貪瞋痴はどのように活動しているのかと発見してください
怒りはわかりやすいんだけど
あの機嫌が悪い時も これは怒りですと
人に悪口言いたくなったら
今怒りが活動中だとかね
より一層美味しいものを食いたいなと
今日はとかね 思ったりと
欲が今活動している というふうな感じで
我々の行為のところで行為を引き起こしているのは貪瞋痴ですね
その時 人と喋る時は 貪瞋痴のどちらかやっているのかどうかチェックするんです
テレビを見ている時は
貪瞋痴はどのように活動しているのかと
テレビを見ている時でも楽しくなったり
悲しくなったり 腹が立ったりしますね
で それで何のこともないニュース流れてるだけなんですけどね
でもこちらはこれ 貪瞋痴で受け取って貪瞋痴を生かしちゃう
そういう風に自分の心をチェックして
貪瞋痴の働き方を発見する
で 三原色は何万通りの色を表すように
貪瞋痴も何千通りもなります
貪瞋痴だからといって単純じゃないんです
三原色と同じ組み合わせでもう何万通りもなってしまいます
なかなか珍しいですよ
ものすごいはっきりと欲で生きている
はっきりと怒りだけで生きているとかね
ないんです あまり なぜならば
一つだけ派手に強くなると
その生命は死ぬんです
耐えられなくなっちゃって
これ三毒だから 仏教用語で三毒というんですね
Three poisons
例えば怒りだけがこみ上げると死にます
無知だけこみ上げてくると
もうどうにもならない
生きていられない すごい危険なものなんです
ですから これはこの中間色にするんですね
我々は 欲があっても これ派手に出さないで
もうちょっと緩和するんですね
怒っても怒ったままで喋ったり行動したりしないで
いくらか欲を混ぜて緩和するんです
例えば怒ってしまった
もうぶん殴りたい相手を
でもこれ殴っちゃうと後からいろいろ出てきて
私が大変やと自分を守る欲が入ってくるんですね
入ってきて すごい怒りがちょっと欲を増したことで緩和しているんですね
それから行動するんです
人を怒鳴りたいんだけど
言いたいこと全部は言わないね
欲の場合も まあ例えば女性の方々はデパートに行ったら
あ これ欲しい 買いたいなと言ったら
値段見てこれ買っちゃうと 1ヶ月間の食事代どうしましょうかとかね
子供の学費どうしますかと
そこで別な欲を入れちゃうんですね
入れて うーん じゃあ買わないことにしましょうということで
欲だけで動かないんですね
我々は毎日そういう生き方をしているんです
三原色で生きてないんです
いつでも組み合わせているんです
完璧でなくても自己観察をしましょう
これは完璧にできてなくてもいいんです
それなりにわかったところで十分です
今 怒りですね 今 欲ですね
今欲ですけど 悩み中と
今は怒りですけど 怒りについても悩み中とか
でも悩み中っていうのは緩和しようかなと緩和しようかしら
ないのかと自分で悩んでるんですね
悩みとは無知が割り込んでいるんです
何か品物を買いたいんだけど
買っちゃおうかな やめようかな
じゃあやめたくはない
でも買い買いたいけど
ちょっと値段が高すぎちゃって
そこで欲に無知が入ってきて
もう判断を鈍くさせちゃうんですね
はい そういうプログラムだから
皆様もわかったところで自己観察してください
瞬間瞬間起こることですけど
瞬間瞬間のことは理解できないんですね
瞑想しない限りは それから相手の行為を観察して
裏にある行為を引き起こさせる感情をチェックします
まず自己観察してから
私だけじゃないでしょ？貪瞋痴は
すべての生命は貪瞋痴でしょ
喋ってるのは私だけじゃないでしょ
誰だって喋ってるでしょ
そこで自己観察完了し
終わったら相手が喋っている
これは貪瞋痴のどちらでしょうか？と
今 この人はすごい興奮している
興奮しているとは 無知が働いている
今 この人の言葉が強烈ということは
この人に今 怒りの感情がある
そのように相手の心を理解していくんです
行為で皆様に心直接アクセスできないだからね
行為はわかりますからね
行為は心がやっちゃったんですね
それで心を見つかるんです
それだけですよ 相手の理解っていうのは
これは決して妄想的 主観的な感想ではないんです
あんた怒っているという勘違いだと
言われない これは自己観察しない人の問題です
この勘違いするのは自己観察しない人なんです
自分の怒りをチェックしたことを一度もなく
あんた怒ってなんだこれはとかね
人に言ったって その人怒ってないかも
その人の言葉使いはそういう言葉使いかも
例えば日本語にしても
丁寧な敬語を使う日本語もありまして
すごい品のない荒っぽい日本語もあるでしょ
荒っぽい日本語を使っているんだからといって
性格悪いとは決められませんよ
よく見たんだけど この中学生の女の子たちが完璧ヤクザみたいな単語を使ってるんです
それまた男の単語で それに性格悪くなくて
あれはあの世界でね 楽しくふざけて生きてるだけです
お母さんに聞けたらお母さんが困るかもしれませんだけど
だからお母さんに聞こえないところで
すごい汚い言葉を使って
また男性が使う言葉を使ったりして
もう女同士であの子どもたちが喋ってるんです
だからそれそれもありますから
これ自己観察していない人だったら
出来の悪い子供たち これはけしからんとんでもない
知識は誰もしていない
危険だと思うかも 全然問題ないんです
あの子供たちも 学校でみんなの前でしゃべることになっちゃうと
結構立派な敬語でしゃべるんです
ですから 自己観察しているならば
この問題は起きません
貪瞋痴は一切の生命に共通です
尺度は客観的です そこで自己観察した人が客観的な尺度を持っています
怒りはこのように働く
怒りはいろんな色を持っている
欲はいろんな色を持っている
その時 このような働きをしていると
この尺度を取っちゃうんです
自分から その尺度で全ての生命に当ててみるだけなんです
自分が善行為をして不貪不瞋不痴を理解できるようになると
尺度 は 6通りになります
もっと拡大します 人を測る尺度は
生命は貪瞋痴ですよ  3つだけです
それもいるわけがもの大変だから
そこで仏道の人だから
これやるのはね 善行為をするんです
善行為をすると 欲ではなくて欲の反対の衝動もわかるんです
あの 不貪というんですね
仏教用語で 怒りではなくて
慈しみをやってみるんですね
そうすると 怒りの反対の衝動も経験できるんです
優しさ そうすると この善行為する人には 6種類の尺度がもっと精密な尺度が出てくるんです
貪瞋痴と不貪不瞋不痴という
その人にはものの見事に
人を理解することができます
なぜかというと この人間
貪瞋痴ですけど いつでも貪瞋痴というわけでもない場合ありますよ
見返り期待しないで人を助けてあげたり
何のことなくいいことをしたり
で 怒っている人の怒りを慰めてあげたり
良いことをやってますよ
宗教と関係ない 宗教があってもなくても
人間が良いこともしています
だから貪瞋痴だけで判断しようとすると
ちょびっと問題が起こる
だから私は善行為までして不貪不瞋不痴も理解する
そうすると ものの見事に人の気持ちは読み取れるんです
はい これで注意点は価値観を入れず
白黒に分けず 判断をせず
あるがままに見ることが必要です
例えば自分の怒りを見るでしょ
ああ これ怒り これ汚い
いやいやいやと思っちゃうと判断しているんですね
怒りを勉強していないんです
判断しない 今は怒っている
それだけ 今喋るんだけど
裏に怒りの感情がある
だから判断せず 価値観入れず見なくちゃ見えないんです
例えば怒りが良くないんだから抑えようとすると
なんか見えなくなっちゃうんですね
はい 次あのシミュレーションというタイトルだったんだけど
私はシミュレーションしないということにするんです
相手を理解する場合は
決してシミュレーションしてはいけません
自分の貪瞋痴を相手にかぶせて見てはいけません
シミュレーションというのは
相手の怒り 自分にかぶすか
自分の怒り相手にかぶすかでしょ
こうやってはいけないんです
やり方は前の最後で説明しました
なぜならば 自分が怒っている時
相手も怒っているように見える可能性あるんですね
だから自己暗示というのは
自分が怒っているのに
なんであんなに怒っているんですかと
本当は自分なんですけど
シミュレーションしてるんですね
で 間違いでしょ 相手が怒っている時
自分も怒ってしまう可能性もあります
逆に誰かが怒っている人が来ると
自分も腹が立ってしまう
これは相手の気持ち 自分に移しちゃったんですね
シミュレーションではそういうことなんです
だから俗世間ではこの余計なことをやめてください
人の怒りに乗りません
人の欲に乗りません 人の無地に乗りません
同時に自分の欲を相手にかぶせません
がお母さんたちがよく子供にやっているんだから
お母さんの見栄やら怒りやら嫉妬やら
全部子供にかぶせちゃう
それで被害者になっちゃうんで
子供は 会社でよくやりますよ
社員に自分の感情をかぶせちゃう
それでは決してうまくいくわけじゃないんです
問題ばかりが起きて調和が壊れます
で こういうこと 貪瞋痴で生きている
私は欲を持って相手の欲と合わせちゃうと
欲が増えるだけ 私が怒ってみんな怒らせてもらう
怒りが増えるだけ 例えば北朝鮮は世界全体に対して怒っている
怒っているのは一匹の人間だけなんですけど
あいつは独裁者で 国民にまでこれ広げちゃうんですね
国民は話を聞いてくれないんだから
軍事国家にしているんです
すべて軍人でなければいけませんと
あのミャンマーでもそうでしたからね
軍人というのは司令通りに動く
人間性を失ったロボットたちなんですね
そうすると自分の貪瞋痴を燃やして広く広げることできます
北朝鮮のリーダーたるあの人の愚かさ
怒り 憎しみ 傲慢さを 北朝鮮のすべてに行き渡っているのです
そこで不幸に陥っているのに気づかない
これよくあるんだ  IS グループは何ですかね
そのグループはすごい巧みに活動して
怒り 憎しみをもうどんどん
ばらまいていくんですね
そうやってはいけないんです
それでは社会の調和が壊されます
そこで次の仏教のポイントは
この 仏教は人格向上を目指しなさいと
生まれて死んで意味がないんだと
生まれて生きて死ぬ 誰だってやるんだから
だから生まれて生きる
だから勉強もする 仕事もする
退職もする 誰だってやることだから
あまりしゃれにならない
だから仏教が推薦する修行とは
人格向上しなさいよと
これを他宗教と比較してください
仏教だけ人のために言ってるんです
神を信仰しなさいと言ってないんです
あなたの人格向上してください
それだけ それであなたが幸福になりますと
ただ生きるのではなく
人格向上を目指して仏教とは生きるのです
貪瞋痴を制御する生き方です
これは人格向上とは 貪瞋痴を制御する生き方です
善行為をして 戒を守って
不貪不瞋不痴の衝動を経験しなくてはいけません
だから我々にとっては新たな経験ですよ
不貪不瞋不痴は だから道徳の中で誰だけわかっている
道徳は至って単純な道徳は布施でしょ
ものをあげること で 人を助けてあげたり
ものをあげたりすると
普段と違った気持ちが生まれるんです
それは喜びなんですね
人に何か金か品物をあげて
相手が助かったと なんか自分がすごく喜びを感じる
あれは不貪の気持ちなんですね
子供二人が喧嘩すると
もう相手に入ってなんで喧嘩するの？まあ言って
そこを解決してあげて
じゃあ仲直りしましょうとかね
はい お互い謝ってくださいとかね
はい 仲良く友達と約束とかね
で 子供たちは約束して
呼び切り なんとか何とかして
また喧嘩やめて仲良くなって
また手をつないでいくと楽しいでしょ
あれは怒りの反対は不審の気持ちなんです
悩み苦しみが少なく 他人他の人々より幸福を経験する生き方ができます
はい これで不貪不瞋不痴のいわゆる戒律を守る
道徳を守る 善行をするなどなどをやると
俗世間と合わないよ 俗世間と合わなくても
自分の人生はうまくいくんです
すごく楽しい すごく幸せ
成功する 失敗はない トラブルはない
こうなってくると さらに人格を向上しようではないかと
できます これから人格向上を目指して様々な試しを行います
その人はもうちょっと頑張ってみようかと
私はちょっとやったことなんですけど
これはただ私はふざけて冗談でやったことで
どこか散歩するときは犬がいたんですね
この犬が家の人間もあまり少ないんだから
足音を聞くとすごく怒って吠えるんですね
なんか道路で人は行ってはいけないような調子なんですね
態度でっかくて 私はこの犬がすごく怒って傲慢で
だから家の人々にかわいがってもらってないでしょうね
まず それである日 私はわさわさと嫌な気持ちになるように
私は歩くことがあまり音は立てませんだけど
わさわさ遠くから音を立てて
こうやって散歩する すると音を犬に聞こえますから
よくね 音を聞こえたところから吠えて吠えて吠えまくってるんですね
私はまだ通ってないんだけどね
で 通っていって それでまた音を立てていて
結局 長い距離で犬が何回も吠えちゃうんで
吠えまくっちゃって苦労するんですね
そこも犬いじめもやめて歩いてね
止まったんです 終わったら気が終わったら悪くなっちゃってね
私はあのね としゃべるんです
なんて勝手に縛って置いたってもね
鎖で繋いでるでしょ 何もできんだからね
バカなことやってるんじゃないとかいろいろしゃべるんです
しゃべると言葉はわからなくても
このしゃべるとこの気持ちが動物には通じますよ
人間に通じないだけでね
そこで犬があれって困っちゃって
悪いな 私は何やってるのかどうかね
わからなくなっちゃって
まあそんな知恵もないんだからね
うーん まあよくわからない
もう戻るぞと言って自分の犬小屋に戻っちゃったんです
で  2回やったらそれからは吠えるのやめたんです
なんでバカなことしなくちゃあかんかと気づいたんですね
だから私にとって楽しい実験だけでね
で 貪瞋痴がなくね この善行をして
不貪不瞋不痴を体験していると
慈しみを体験していると
そういう面白いことができます
はい そういうことでいろいろ楽しみができます
はい 次に行きます 再度番号がなくなっちゃったね
うん はい これからブッダの言葉になります
自分と合わせてみる サッベータサンティダンダササッベーバヤンティマッチュアッターナンウパンカトアナハニエネガーテダンマパダ百二十九すべての生命は罰ってい
うのは
この苦しみ いじめることですね
に怯える 死を怯える 自分を例として見て
他の他をいじめないこと
他を殺さないこと これ自己観察しなさいという意味なんです
すべての生命がもういじめられること
殴られること 痛みつけることは嫌なんです
怯えるんです 例えば みんな犯罪しないのは警察に逮捕されるのは嫌だからなんです
裁判から刑務所に入れるのは嫌なんです
それから死ぬことを怯えるんです
これは他の生命だけじゃなくて
自分もそうでしょう だから素直に自己観察する
自分がいかに馬鹿にされるのは嫌なのか
いかにいじめられることは嫌なのか
怒られることはいかに嫌なのか
そこを考えて他人にやらないこと
ここで善行をするために
悪をやめるために 自分の気持ちを他人に当ててみるんですね
あの他人に当ててみた
自分の気持ちは 前 私やるなよと言ったでしょ
皆様のやり方なんです
貪瞋痴を当てるんです
これをやらない 仏教で
もっと生命の基本的な気持ち
生きていきたい 死にたくない
いじめられてほしくない
それには貪瞋痴 それほど関係ない
あの気持ちで相手気持ちを相手にかぶしてみるんです
私はこの野郎と言われると気持ち悪いんだからね
じゃあ私も相手に対してこの野郎と言わない
例えば 私はあんた何の能力もないね
あなたは って言われると気持ち悪いでしょ
そういう言葉を他人に対しては語らない
だから自分の気持ちをまず見て
そこは貪瞋痴とそれほど関係ない
それを他人にかぶる はい
次の言葉に行きます 命が大好きというね
サッベータシンダンダササッベータンジーヴィタンピヤンアッターナンウパンカトアナハニエネガーテ
すべての生命は罰苦しみに怯える
すべての生命は自分の命が好きです
大好きです 自分を例として見て
他をいじめないこと 他を殺さないこと
自分が自分の命を大好きです
この上のない価値を入れています
それは他の生命に当てはめて
他をいじめない気持ちをいじめたい気持ちを制御します
我々は獣だから他をいじめたい
痛みつけたい 殺したいんですね
これやめてほしい やめる方法は
このかぶってみるんです
相手にかぶせてみるんです
自分の気持ちを 自分がいじめられてほしくない
これは私に自分の母親が教えた道徳で
動物をいじるなよ あれやあれやではなくて
殺すなよではなくてね
いつでも自分がそうなったらどう？と聞くんですね
だからそれ一回 二回しか言われてないんです
すごい小さい時 一回ね
小鳥一匹捕まってやろうと思ったんです
罠をかけて で 無性にいるんだから
当時ではね ものすごい鳥たちが
だから一匹は取れるぞと思っていて
餌をまいて罠をかけて待っていたんですね
で 母にバレちゃって 捕まる前に鳥を
あなたはそこまでいたらどう？あなたはそこまで檻に入れたらどうですかと
だから母親がものの見事にお釈迦様のこのやり方で
お説教ないんです いじめるなよと
なんとかとかね お釈迦様のこの真髄の教えで言ったんです
シミュレーションしてくださいと
私はまあ四歳 五歳ぐらいだと思いますけど
すぐシミュレーション始めたんです
それから私は人を馬鹿にすることはちっちゃい時からないんです
時々気持ち悪いやつだなってあるんだけど
言わない そう思ってはいかんよと
だからこの修行というのは
私はもう母親から教えてやってきたものなんです
いや 母親も母親で 本当にもうよくこのブッダの言葉ではなく
この裏にあるメッセージをよく取っていたんですね
だから ギャーギャーギャー言うことなんのことなく
一言で終わります いつでも失敗するたびに何か一言葉だけちらっと言うで終わり
こんな感じで なんだこれ
あれやこれやそうじゃないんです
だからブッダの教えの真髄わかると大変便利ですよ
今 73 で 私は未だに守ってるんだから
あのしつけを  皆幸福が好き
สุขカマーニブータニヨダンデーナヴィヒンサティ
アッタノสุขメーサーノペッチャソナラバテーสุข
アッタノสุขメーサーノペッチャソラバテーสุข
例二つですね 幸福楽しみを好む生命を自分の幸福のためにいじめる
悩ませるならば その後
その人は幸福になりません
あのいじめるとき 瞬間の快楽はあるんだけど
それからガクンで人生壊れてしまいます
なぜならば これ生命の法則です
誰もみんなสุขカマーニブータニ
幸福に生きていきたいんです
ゴキブリさえも 幸せになりたいんです
だったら人をいじめるなよ
他の生命をいじめるなよと
幸福に生きたいと思う人
思う生命をいじめない人は
その後幸福になります
だからずっと幸福に生きたければ
他人をいじめないことです
他人も幸福になりたいと理解すること
これは自分の気持ちを相手にかぶってシミュレーションすることなんです
これは正しいやり方です
だから仏道を歩んだらシミュレーションしてくださいです
仏道歩む気持ちがなかったらやめてください
シミュレーションは あなたはもう世界を破壊する人間になる
仏道の人がシミュレーションすると
その人も幸福で 周りも幸福になる
自分の気持ちを他にかぶせてみることですね
はい 次 感情の組み合わせ
自分の欲を他人にかぶせてみると
相手も相手にも欲が生じる
必ず同じ形ではない 私の欲を相手にかぶっちゃうと
相手の欲が生じる 同じ形の欲じゃない
複雑ですけど ただ 私は嫌な気分で
いわば怒りでね 相手にもかぶせちゃう
そうすると相手は怒りを反応するんだけど
私と同じ怒りじゃないんです
違う形 もっとわかりやすい例がないか
じゃあ私は相手の金を欲しがる
欲しがっていろんな欲でしょ？なんとか騙してあの金を取ってやるぞと
だからいろいろ提案する
金を取りたくて あるいは自分に何の価値もない品物を何か家から持って
これってすごくいいでしょうね
じゃああなたにありますからね
私に 1万円くれない？とかね
そうすると相手が私の欲を感じるんですよ
あ この人の欲で私のものを取ろうとする
それで相手が反応します
怒りに対して この人はすごい超気持ち悪い
なかなかこの人の欲がもう終わらない
だから人付き合いやめましょう
とりあえずとりあえず逃げたい
だからお金もあげて あなたの品物もいりませんよと
持ってください さようならと逃げる可能性もある
あるいはあげるもんかと思って
逆に自分が欲しいものを何かあるのかと見て
1万ではなくて6万ぐらい高価なものを見て
まあこれが欲しいな これくれるんだったらあげますよとかね
という態度をとる可能性もありますね
そういうわけで 怒りを相手にかぶせちゃうと
相手も怒りで反応する
それはどんな怒りかよくわからない
人によって違う それによってさらに自分の欲が強化します
それになってくると 自分の欲がさらに強化します
例えば 私が1万円取りたくなったから
もうちょっと頭がおかしくなっちゃって
その人にこれあげれば1万円くれるでしょうとか思っちゃうんですね
で あげる あげたら1万円来る
あれ 6万円の品物を取られたと 1
万円もらったんだけど
私の欲がさらに増えちゃうでしょうね
損しちゃった だからもっとやらなくちゃいけないんだ
もっとずる賢く金を握ってやらなくちゃいけないということになるんだ
怒りを他人に当てると他人も怒る
その怒りが反射するので
自分の怒りが壮大します
それで悪循環が生まれる
怒りを相手にぶつけると相手も来る
それで相手の怒りが自分に来るんだから
自分がさらに怒る 例えばお前バカじゃない？お前がバカでしょと言われると
私はもう倍怒っているんです
もともと怒っていたのに
その上バカに言われたんだ
バカだと言われたんだから
だからガクンと怒りが壮大してしまいます
ムチも同じこと 自分のムチを相手にぶつけると
相手のムチが自分に返ってきて
どんどんムチが大きくなってきます
ですから 決して貪瞋痴は相手にかぶせません
貪瞋痴のシミュレーションは決してしてはいけません
それは人格向上ではなく
人格なんていうのか 堕落の道になるんです
貪瞋痴のシミュレーションは絶対危険です
また 感情の組み合わせ
相手の貪瞋痴を読めた人は
相手に対して不貪不瞋不痴で対応します
これは仏教の人でしかできません
相手が怒っていると優しさで対応するんです
慈しみで対応するんです
相手に欲があるとわかったら
布団で物をあげることで
対応するんです あるいはあげなくても
あんたそんな欲持っちゃうとやばいよ
もっと損しますよとかね
で 不痴 いわゆる知恵で対応する
貪瞋というのは不貪不瞋不痴でいいと
不痴とは知恵なんですね
あんた持ってるお金もなくなりますよ
例えば ちょっと怪しいところに投資しようとする
すごい利益があるんだと
あのね 利益あるんだったら
みんなさっさとそれ投資しているでしょ
だからわざわざあなたにお金出してください
出してください そんなに責めるということは
あれは嘘じゃない 簡単に儲けるんだったら
その人は金出して儲かっちゃいますよと
だから あんたの預金でそれでいいんでしょうと
利益がなくてもという風に知恵でアドバイスすることもできる
だから 貪瞋痴の感情に対して
仏教徒は不貪不瞋不痴で対応して
あの毒を消すんです 解毒をあげるんです
世間は毒をさらに毒で強化されるんですね
必ず相手の悪感情が消えて
相手が安らぎを感じます
自分が善行したので 自分も徳を積んだことになります
そこで 相手の貪瞋痴に我々は不貪不瞋不痴で対応すると
相手も安らぎを感じる
自分も善行したことになる
そこで悪循環の反対 良い循環が善循環が現れるんです
次 苦しみのお返し マーウォーチョパルサンカンチェウッターパティワディユタン
ドゥッカアイサーランバカタパティダンダークゼユタン
決して粗悪語を語らないこと
相手も同じ言葉で言い返すのです
対立する いわゆる喧嘩になり
言葉 なりじゃない 対立するになる言葉は苦しみです
喧嘩になる言葉って嫌です
苦しいんです これは言葉の制御についてお釈迦様が語った文章なんですね
決して粗悪語を喋らないということ
なぜならば 聞いた相手も同じことをやっちゃいますよと
だって相手が一般人でしょう
仏教徒じゃないでしょ
仏教徒でない人に粗悪語を喋ったら
相手はもうより強い粗悪語を返しちゃうんです
そうすると言葉の喧嘩になる
人間の喧嘩にもなる 喧嘩が苦しいのです
やめた方が良いと 相手を殴ったりするならば
自分もお返しを受けるんです
お返し欲しい？欲しくないでしょ
だったらやらないこと
幸福になりたいという自分の気持ちを相手に当てはめてみることです
だから 自分を見て 自分が幸福になりたい
それは伊藤に当ててみるんです
人の幸福を壊さないことに頑張るんです
それで自分が幸福になるんです
簡単な方法です 自分が幸福になりたければ
ハチャメチャ頑張らなくていいんです
自分が幸福になりたい
ハチャメチャ頑張りませんだけど
人の幸福は壊さない 気をつける
それだけです みるみるうちに自分が幸福になるだけじゃなくて
人格向上もします はい
最後のセクション 慈しみ
慈しみを必ずシミュレーションします
ちょっと休んだ方がいいと思いますけど
時間的に続けています
私ではなくて 知識的にちょっと休めるべきところなんです
ちょっと休みます はい
これからはまるっきり別なタイトルになります
慈しみというものをシミュレーションするんです
慈しみとは人格向上案です
慈悲の瞑想は慈悲喜捨の実践でエゴの錯覚が消えます
生命はライバルではなく味方になります
慈しみを実践すると すごいいいことでしょ？みんな味方だよと
こんな幸福ある？ 1 まず自分が幸福になりたい人間であることを繰り返し確認して
頭に心に叩き込む 順番にやってください
まず 私が幸せになりたい
これを叩き込んでください
心に 私が悩み苦しみは嫌です
私がやることは成功したいんです
それは希望を叶えたいということ
これは本気 失敗したくない
私はバカで生きていくない
智慧があってほしい 賢く生きていきたい
これは慈悲の瞑想の 4 行目
悟りの光が現れますように
と まず自分に慈悲をやってください
やって 繰り返し繰り返し言って
言って言って 頭に叩いて
叩いて 素直に幸せになりたいという人間になってください
今はハチャメチャでしょ
心が 正直じゃない 幸せになりたい気持ちがすっごく隠れているんです
ものすごい荷物の下に
だから この自分で自由を実践して実践して
あの文章を知っているでしょ？あの文章
私は幸せでありますように
私の悩み苦しみがなくなりますようにと本気で念じてみてください
念じて心変えてください
親しい生命も同じであると確認する
次に親しい生命を あの気持ちをね
当てはめてみるんです
みんなも幸せになりたい
悩み苦しみなくなりたいと思っている
自分のこの素直な気持ち
自分がもう疑いなく揺らぎなく
幸せになりたいとしっかりしているんです
幸せを目指してやるぞと
幸せに生きるぞと あの目指してやるぞというのは仏教的な言葉ではないんです
幸せに生きるぞと いつでも現在形に使わなくしなくちゃいけないんです
それから周りも親しい生命も
ああ 幸せでいてほしい
幸せにしてあげます という自分の気持ちを強くするんです
それから 一切の生命も同じ気持ちであると確認する
それ終わったら あの気持ちを自分自身の気持ちでしょ
これをシミュレーションなんです
もう一度言います 私が今中途半端
今いい加減な人間で それで私は幸せになりたい
私は悩み苦しみがなくなってほしい
私の希望を叶ってほしい
私に知恵が現れてほしい
という 自分が幸せな人間になりたい
なります なります なりますと言って
言い返して言い返して
なんか幸せだけ光るように
幸せだけ自分が訴えになるような人間になる
それからその気持ちをシミュレーションする
親しい人々に当てはめてみる
この人は字の瞑想してないんだけど
自分の奥さんは字の瞑想してないんだけど
この人もやっぱり私と同じく幸せ三昧でいきたいでしょうね
言って無理やりかぶせてみるんです
そこでなんとなく奥さんも自分に対して光って見えるんですね
幸せになりたくて 悩み苦しみが嫌で
成功する生き方をして
賢く生きていきたい 奥さんがいて
子供がいて 友達がいて
親しい生命だ それができたならば
すべての生命も結局同じことだと
あの気持ちをとことん拡大してみるんです
はい すべての生命は慈悲喜捨を期待して望んでいることを確認しましょう
ただ確認する 一切の生命は慈悲喜捨を期待している
望んでいる それは否定する生命はいませんと
メッタ友情 これ慈悲喜捨の慈ですね
えーと 自分も他人も好む気持ちです
じゃあ項目ごとに勉強しましょう
慈悲喜捨の一番目はメッタ友情
私は友情が欲しいんです
この人も友情が欲しいんです
あの人も友情が欲しいんです
ゴキブリさんも友情が欲しいんです
だから友情がいいなと思う気持ちがすべての生命にある
自分のメッターを他人の潜在的なメッターとつなげてみるんです
例えばゴキブリは慈悲の瞑想していないんです
ゴキブリのメッターが寝ているんです
潜在的ですね 自分がその潜在感情にコンタクトするんです
電信柱に鳥が止まっていると
この鳥は慈悲の瞑想してないんです
しかし この鳥さんも友達が欲しいんです
友情が欲しいんです だから自分がその鳥を見て
この友情でコンタクトします
自分も他人もこの気持ちでは同等であるという気持ちで
相手と適切な関係を結ぶ
はい これで私もゴキブリも小鳥も人間も犬も猫も
すべての生命が友情を期待している
目に見えない生命も 幽霊たちも霊たちも神々も
みんな友情を期待している
そこでこの相手が慈悲の瞑想するかしないかどうでもいい話で
気持ちが寝ているんです
逆らうわけにはいきません
私は敵が欲しいと思っている人がいないでしょ
私が苦しみが欲しいやと思っているバカがいない
ただ慈悲の瞑想していないだけで
私たちは人の表面的な心ではなく
この深く寝ている慈悲喜捨にコンタクト取るんです
コンタクト取ると次 何かわかる
生命って平等だと 気持ち的にみんな同じだと
あの表でちょこちょこと違いますけどね
例えばクマさんが私を見たら攻撃しますが
それはクマさんの表の人生なんです
でもクマさんにしたっても
心の中で友情が欲しいんです
幸福になりたいんです
悩み苦しみは嫌なんです
それわかってから私はクマさんと適切な関係を結ぶんです
適切な関係って何でしたっけ？クマがいるところには絶対行かないことです
それは関係です だってクマはクマだから
クマにも表面的な生き方があるんだからね
それに邪魔しない 人間に対して友情が広がったんだからって
人間みんな友達にしちゃうと困るでしょ
だから適切な関係 電車に乗る
電車にいっぱい人がいる
自分はみんな平等で みんな慈悲喜捨を期待している生命だと理解して
適切な関係を結ぶんです
どういう関係かというと
まあ黙って電車に乗って
人に迷惑をかけないで
自分の駅で降りる それだけよ
ちゃんとコミュニケーション関係を持ってるんです
ねえねえ あなたと喋る必要ないんです
我々の国では喋りますけどね
電車に乗ったら バスに乗ったら
みんな互いに喋るんです
別に知り合いじゃないんです
喋るは喋るは終わりがない
やはり私の文化では 知らない人だったら喋れなきゃすごい道徳違反やと思ってるんです
喋りながら一緒に紅茶を飲んだり
コーヒーのいろいろやりますよ
はい ですから この適切な関係を結ぶということをよく理解してください
ハブ ハブでしたっけ？あの毒蛇がハブってね
ハブは幸せになりたいでしょ
それでハブと自分が同等でしょ
ハブも全然もう何も考えてないんだけど
慈悲喜捨は寝ているんです
あの心に そこでコンタクトしてハブと適切な関係を結ぶんです
いわゆるハブが隠れているところには行かないこと
それが慈しみの行為なんです
他の 3つについても同じく修行しましょう
一応他の 3つの説明だけ言います
カルナという気持ち カルナっていうのは
バックと悩みの苦しみが嫌だ
なくなってほしいとかね
動物も病気になっちゃうと治療できればありがたいと思ってますよ
でもそれ考えないんだから
病気になったらそのまま死ぬかもしれませんだけどね
2番目 ムディタ 他の幸福を喜ぶことですね
嫉妬しないで 人が幸せにいると自分と喜びます
鳥たちがキーキーキーキーと鳴いて遊んでいると
ああ なんて幸せですかと自分を楽しめばいいんです
ウペッカーシャ それ 平等ということですね
生命は平等です 慈悲喜捨から見れば
それを発見してコンタクトを取ってください
生命は自分に対してプライドを持っています
対等に接してほしいと思っています
このウペッカーのことなんですね
生命というのは ゴキブリであってもすごいプライド持ってますよ
だからこのゴキブリはパシッとやっちゃうとウペッカーじゃないんですね
だからこのウペッカーはすべての生命にあるんです
シャという気持ちが みんな自分のプライドを持っていて
対等であってくださいと見下すなよと思っているんです
だから誰だって犬猫だって見下すのは嫌なんです
それはウペッカーという気持ちなんです
他の生命は基本的に期待している慈悲喜捨の気持ちを
自分の同じ気持ちで合わせて気持ちと合わせてシミュレーションしてみます
これはシミュレーションし方なんです
だから相手が瞑想するかしないかどうでもいいんです
相手にこれあるんです
すごく隠れて慈悲喜捨
だから自分が慈悲喜捨でいっぱいになって
相手にもこれで当てはめてみて
照らしてかぶせてあげて
コミュニケーションコンタクトを取ってみるんです
素晴らしい世界が現れますよ
今と違ったまるっきり別世界が見えてくるんです
みんな平等で 表のくだらないことは気にしない
だから今はクリスマスだからみんな赤い服を着て帽子かぶって
とかね なんとか言ってピザ屋さんとかね
そういう感じになりますけど
どこでもサンタばっかしでね
プライドチキンのところでもね
よく私の目に入るところでね
まあバカやと思いますけど
まあ次の日行ったらまた普通にいるんですね
だからなんで我々はこのクリスマス時
みんな赤い服を着ているんだから
これやと認識するんですか？この人はサンタさんやと勘違いでしょ
だから被り物の中を見ましょう
人間というのは被り物です
コマって被り物です ゴキブリって被り物です
それでコミュニケーション取っちゃうと勘違いもいいところなんです
何か被ったらそれに合わせた生き方をするだけなんです
裏に慈悲喜捨でみんな同じで繋がっているんです
それはご自分で体験してほしい
そうするとすごい別世界
はい シミュレーションが成功すると
他を見るとき 他人ではなく形の違う心が似ている自分自身が見えてきます
これが大事なポイントなんで
生命は自分自身ということ
で このスライドのアニメーションは入れてないんだから
一瞥で全部出ますけどね
自分自身が見えてくるんですよ
ゴキブリを見ても自分を見ているんです
あれ 被り物 ヘビを見ても自分を見るんです
ヘビの体は被り物 ヘビの脳は被り物
ヘビの生き方は被り物
中生命として同じなんです
だからあなたは私ですと
私があなたですと このウパニシャッド哲学で言っている言葉なんです
タットマシと That
is you That is your self なんです
正しい英語で言えば 例えば人を見せて
これ誰？これは男性です
日本人です 違います That
is you これは女性です
女性 なんだ 女性って それはあなたですと
それでこのコミュニケーションを取っちゃえば
慈悲喜捨で 私はあなたで
あなたが私になっちゃうんです
次に 体に隠れて見えなくなった生命のことを感じられます
自分と他人の差がなくなりますね
だけど あの人私になっちゃったんだからね
私はあの人になっちゃったんだから
心という無限の大交換を感じます
それって自分の心ですよ
自分の心はどんな心にも繋がっちゃうんです
生命は無限でしょ なんか自分の心は突然無限と感じるんです
そこに自分も他人も存在しない
慈悲喜捨のサマーディです
これをサマーディと言うんです
これちょっと余計なことを言いたいんだけど
この命の根源にコンタクトしたことになるんです
すべての命の 他宗教の単語で言えば
神とコンタクトを取ったんです
ヒンドゥー教的に言えば
自分が神になったんです
この心で これは宗教の単語で仏教は使いませんだけど
でも仏教でも慈悲はここまでやっちゃうと
ブラフマヴィハール梵天の生き方
梵天になっちゃってる
あなたはと 梵天というのは昔インドで絶対的神に使う単語なんです
ここまでできますよ いたって簡単に
やらないだけで では その人にどれぐらいエネルギーあると思う？一切の生命の根源とつながっている
悩み苦しみもある 何か解決できない問題どうかある？何もないんです
はい シミュレーションの場合はそこまでです
で 解脱の場合は別なヴィパッサナーの道で別なものを教えます
これで今日のお話は終了します
どうもありがとうございます
まだ若干お時間が四時半ですので
あります あまりたくさんの方にマイクを回さないとですけど
何人かの方もしご質問ある方いらっしゃいましたらマイクお願いします
どうもありがとうございました
慈悲の瞑想について教えてください
私は今 慈悲の瞑想をしていて
その私の親しい人々が
私の親しい生命が幸せであるようにというふうに念じますと
あの 自分の体のそのバイリンとかがイメージされて
それで空間も そうですね
いろんな生き物がイメージします
で 幸せであるようにと念じて
それ私の初めての体験で
とても気に入ってるんですけども
ただですね その今日の講演の前も初めに慈悲の瞑想をしましたけども
そのなかなか人間に到達しないんですね
その人間 隣にいらっしゃる方の周りにバイキンがついてる
バイキンって変なんですけどね
いろんな命の中にかりそめに姿があるような感じで
人間に到達しないし それからあと生きとし生けるものがって言った時も
そこで広がっていかないんですね
すいません ご指導をお願いいたします
はい これはあの貪瞋痴で生きている私が
この超越した世界はまずわからないんですね
だから順番でゆっくりと進むんですね
だからまず言葉で念じることをするんです
で 言葉念じること止めませんよ
止めませんだけど なぜならば妄想しちゃうんだからね
で 今日紹介したのは この言葉で念じるだけじゃないんだよと
ちょっとサマーディに持っていく裏の話がありますと
今日はあまり普段紹介してないんです
このセクションは今日紹介するところは
だからこれは経験というかね
体験というか 体験なんですね
体験が自分がするんです
だから言葉はでもダラダラダラダラ念じたってもいいんだけど
言葉念じながらもう体験するんですね
私が幸せでありますように
セクションがます この瞑想をやる場合は
まず私が幸せでありますようにだけやるんです
だけ それだけやっちゃって当たり前
私は幸せな人間になりたいということはと当たり前になってから
親しい人々にも 生命にも
親しい生命にも同じ気持ちを広げてみるんですね
みんなも同じだ みんなも同じだと
それからみんなも同じやっていうことを体験するんです
自分が体験すると 私はちょっと他宗教の考えも使っちゃったんだから
今日はね で 相手が瞑想してないんですよ
瞑想してないんだけど
相手の心の中に自意識者が寝ているんですね
微妙に寝ているんです
その上で命が成り立っているんです
だから 相手のいわゆる親しい生命の自意識者を自分が体験する
そうすると 自分にとって自分と親しい生命っていうのは一つのグループで
一つの水たまりのようになっちゃうんです
ちょっと大きい水たまり
大きい湖 湖の中で水の間では差がないでしょ
で そういう風にこの気持ちを広げる
それ何か月間でも体験できるところまでやってから
3番目に生きとし生けるものはと
そうすると すべての生命のどんどんやっていると
最初はいくらなんでもゴキブリは嫌ですよとかね
出てくるかも でもそこを抑えて
これはかぶりもので ゴキブリはかぶりもので
脳細胞もかぶりもので
生き方もかぶりもので
それと違って命やと 命ですから自意識者があるんだと
そこでコンタクトして湖が大海にするんです
だから自分自身が大海になるんですね
自分自身がもう無限の大空間になっちゃうんです
自分の心がそうやって拡大するんです
そうすると すごい命とのコンタクトが成り立つんです
その順番でこの瞑想をするんです
普通は それで 毎バージョンでいろいろ試し試してみた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
だから広げないということはあまり大きい問題ではないんです
広げるためにどうすればいいかと考えた方がいいんじゃないかなと思います
今日は本当の瞑想のやり方を説明しました
慈悲の瞑想 シミュレーションです
それは 私たちはすべての生命が自意識者を実現してほしいと余計なわがままを言いません
ではなくて ゴキブリさんも幸せになりたいでしょうとかね
そうすると面白いんですよ
もう昆虫たちも虫たちもね
本当に素晴らしく見えてくるんです
私の場合は 人間にとってちょっと仲良くすることのできない生命体は
私がいると避けてくれるんです
あなたと仲良くできませんからと
でも向こうは怒ってないんです
私も向こうに対して怒り憎しみを持ってないんです
それで この間 私は山口の清浄寺で働いていて
部屋にいて 朝起きて窓を開けたんですから
窓の横に巣が巣を作っていたんですね
蜘蛛が でっかい巣のくがあるんだなとかね
見たら細長い蜘蛛さんで足 1本ないんですね
すごい足が長い種類で
体が細長くて あれ これ違う種類かなと
蜘蛛って 6本持ってるはずなんですけどとかね
よくよく見ると1本が壊れているんですね
そこでその蜘蛛さんが私がいることがわかったんですね
わかって私はすぐに邪魔してないんです
そうすると避けたんですね
避けたら迷惑ですねと言って
私は窓を閉めたんです
それからほんのちょっと時間経って
まだ用事があって窓を開けたら
あの蜘蛛さんが巣を全部畳んで持っていて
どこかに行っているんです
自分で だから蜘蛛さんがよくえらいことを考えちゃったんです
これは人間には迷惑だと
この人に それで私は窓から出たり入ったりすることは自由にできたし
こうやって転がっていく必要なかったしね
あるいは蜘蛛の巣を破っちゃって悪口言う必要もなかったんです
本人が自分の家を全部巻いて持っていて
どこかのところに だからそういうことを感じると楽しくない？だから蜘蛛は何考えてどうせわかりません
だけど 私は自意識者のところでコンタクトするだけ
だから私にとっては足一本なくなった蜘蛛さんも私も同じなんですね
足一本がなくてね 本当に大変でしょ 6
本も一緒だから だから私はそう感じますよ
例えば両手でこうやって巣を糸
引いたりするでしょ 尾っぽから出して
こうやって手でやって 1本も手ないんだからね
だからあの子が次の足でこの訓練しなくちゃいけないでしょ
もう八本じゃない  えっ？ もう八八本じゃない
八本でしたっけ？わかる
で よくわからない そんなのは
だからね 大変でしょ 一本なくなると
だからあの動物はそうやって怪我しているとか
スリランカの動物 ゾウさんの孤児院もありましてね
もう野生で怪我したり
生活できなかったものを持ってきて
餌をあげて面倒見ているところでね
だから人 一匹のゾウさんがいて
足ないんですね 一本 なんか地雷
何かにやられちゃって
だから三本であの巨体で歩くっていうことがね
大変ですよ だからあまりみんなにバレるんだからやりませんだけど
誰もない場合は 私はいろんな生命にこういう自引き車でコンタクトしてみるんですよ
本当にすごいんです 凶暴でも何でもないんです
もう仲間になっちゃうんです
仲間になっても この被り物で生形が変わりますから
人間に邪魔だったら向こうは自分でもう避けてくれる
一緒にいても別にいいんじゃないかなと思っちゃうと
ああ 一緒にいてくれたりする
そういうことで このちょっとこの
これ体験してみてください
慈悲を いきなりできません
いきなりサマーディは生まれません
はい すみません  はい  一生懸命体験しようと思ってます
それでですね あの 私はその生き生命というと
その自分がこう 木になったような気持ちがするんですけども
それはだから広がっていかないんでしょうか
教えてください  だから
それもまだまだあるリミットがかかってるんだから
あまり大したことじゃないと思いますけど
そんな気にしなくたってもね
自分という気持ちが消えた方がいいんですね
自分がどこやと 例えば体って 40兆の細胞でしょ？細胞はまた他の生命と組み合わせて生きているだけで
そちらに自分がいないんだからね
すみません しつこくて
えっとですね 私たち 40兆の細胞ですよね
でもなんか腸内細菌はなんか 1000兆あるそうなので
そうそうそう  それだからもうそういう風にこう
命 命って考えていくと
どんどんどんどん植物的になるっていうんでしょうか
その動く なくなって 他の動物の方まで届かないんですけど
はい これはこのちょっと体のこと気にしすぎやと思いますね
瞑想は心ですね だから形はどうでもいいんです
何兆の生命体がいたっても
心はそれぞれ別やというふうに見た方がいいんじゃない？例えば小さな生命であっても生命なんです
心があって かぶり物があって生きているんですね
だから 何兆ぐらいですか？腸内細菌は
えっ  1 兆ってすごい量なんですね
すごい重いんですよ だから 1 兆もそれぞれ生命体なんですね
だから肉体を忘れましょう
これ 肉体を忘れる訓練でもある
心にコンタクトする そちらに別に大きさはないんです
心には 心は物じゃないんだからね
だから体のことをもうちょっと控えてね
体にじゃあ入れちゃうと
なんか細菌になってしまう可能性ありますから
これ体じゃないの 心ですね
心はすべての生命に 1個 1個平等にあるんです
はい とりあえずそれしか言えないんです
今は はいはい 瞑想は経験に入れ替えてください
最終的に結論は はい 他の質問があるならば
はい えーとですね 正思惟
サンマーサンカッパはメッターとカルマとネッカマの 3つになるということなんですけども
その八正道にはロキアとロクッタラとありまして
ロクッタラ 出世間のサンマーサンカッパ
正思惟の場合に どういうことになるかというと
そのメッター カルナ ネッカマが何を思考しようとしても
メッター カルナ ネッカマになるということを聞いたのですが
その無条件の慈悲が完成するということと
そのネッカマ利用よくよくわからないですけど
ネッカマと無条件の慈悲が完成するということがどのように関連連携しているのでしょうか
分けてください 慈悲の瞑想とヴィパッサナー瞑想ね
分けてください これはいつでも合体できるわけじゃないんです
八正道 の八正道は解脱に達する道で
で それには他の生命は関係ないんです
慈悲喜者は他の生命との関係ですから
最高のところに達したっても
生命の根源に戻るだけ
まだ生命脱出していないんです
だから ヴィパッサナー瞑想もやらなくちゃいけないんです
まあ今日はこのシミュレーションのね
相手の気持ちを理解するテーマですから
私はこの九国のレベルまでどうやって相手を理解するのかと説明してたんです
即席の話ではないんだけどね
これだけ仏教じゃないんですよ
輪廻脱出することが 涅槃に達することは仏教なんです
だから分けてください
はい  わかりました  えーと
言葉の問題なんですけど
シミュレーションっていうのは自分の中でこう考えてみるということで
それを他の生命に向けるのがコンタクトという感じでいいんでしょうか
伝わったなっていうのはコンタクトした感じでいいんでしょうか
あまり聞き取れなかったんで
シミュレーションっていうのは
自分の中で自身で瞑想することで
コンタクトっていうのは
それを相手に向けてみるとか
伝わったかなっていう感じでいいんでしょうか
あのコンタクトの場合は
相手が必ずコンタクトしてくれるってことじゃない
自分がコンタクトするだけの話なんです
自分がコンタクトする
相手は別に無関心でいいんです
だから誰でもコンタクトはできます
自分の心で 相手が反応する場合
しない場合 いろいろ それは関係ない
例えば自意識の木あるで喜び
私の場合でもね 今日みたいな土曜日とか日曜とか
朝は結構子供たちの遊んでいる声が聞こえるんですね
それで私は気持ちで元気で
今日は休みだからみんな楽しくいるなとかね
よかったなと自分が喜びを感じるんです
子供たちがガチャガチャガチャ遊んだりしてね
お互いに子供たちの世界があってね
いろいろお互いに話し合ったりしてやってる世界を見て
私は自分の喜びを感じる
それで子供たちも楽しいんだけど
そこで私からはコンタクトがしてますが
子供たちは私の存在すらも知らないんです
私は部屋の中にいるんだから
外を出たっても 私から見れば
この子供たちの心の中まで全部知ってるんだけど
子供たちはもうあれ みんなキリスト教の幼稚園に行ってるんだからね
こんにちはすらも言わないんですね
だから別にそれは私にとってはあんまり関係なくてね
だから物理的なコンタクトしないんです
時々この田舎にやってくると
この八王子ぐらいもうちょっといろいろ行ってみると
もうまあ調布の一回調布の方でうろうろ歩いたことがあってね
学校終わって子供が出てきて
まあ大変ですよ もう飛んできて喋ったり
衣を引っ張ったり いろんなことをやっちゃうんですね
だからそこで子供たちの方からもコンタクトする
別に子供たちは遠慮なく
私もどうやって早く逃げていくのかとかね
対応しますよ 楽しく子供たちの質問に答えたり
いろいろちょこちょこと遊んであげたり
いろんなことをやったりするんだけど
もうとにかく早く帰りたいという気持ちもないわけじゃないんですね
だから 自由な瞑想で自分からコンタクトを取って
命の根源になるまでやらなくちゃいけないんですね
これ 他宗教の単語は妄想概念形而学ですけど
わかりやすいんですね
神の心にコンタクトするっていうね
ですから ゴキブリさんの気持ちをわかったからって
ゴキブリさんが寄ってこないよ
逃げます 寄ってきても困るでしょうしね
それでよろしいですか
はい  はい すいません そろそろ時間になりましたので
これで終了したいと思います
皆さん ありがとうございます
はい 最後の祈願を唱えましょう
一緒に唱えましょう では
3回唱えます はい ドゥッカパッターチェニン
ドゥッカバヤン パッタチェニンバヤ
ソーカムパッタチェニッソーカホントサンディピパニノ
ドゥッカムパッタチェニン
ドゥッカバヤン パッタチェニンバヤ
ショーカパッパッタチェニッソーカホント
サンデーピパニノ ドゥッカムパンターチャニンドゥッカ
バヤンパンターチャニンバヤ
ショーカンパンターチャニッショーカ
オントゥサンデーティパニノ
苦しんで悩む生命が苦しみなく
恐れて悩む生命が恐れなく
悲しんで悩む生命が悲しみなく
一切の生命が安穏でありますように
はい ありがとうございます
サーリ サーリ サーリ